[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact the world's largest doors
are those for the NASA vehicle assembly
building better known as the VA be at
the Kennedy Space Center on Merritt
Island Florida the building designed as
a place to assemble rockets enrolled
them to the launch pad is the fourth
largest structure in the world by volume
and it was the largest structure when
originally completed in 1965 at 526 feet
it is still the tallest building in the
United States outside of an urban area
where this building really shatters
records is the entrance the VAB contains
by far the largest doors in the world
each of its four doors measure 456 feet
high
in contrast the Statue of Liberty is
only 305 feet high meaning if you could
put the Statue of Liberty on wheels you
could easily roll it through the Gateway
of this building and still have a
hundred and fifty feet to spare because
of their colossal size the VAB doors
take 45 minutes to open and close you
know the Bible talks about an even
bigger door that opens more quickly stay
with his friends we're going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
lie
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 seven two nine
seven we're also broadcasting right now
on Facebook and you can see what's
happening here in the studio as well as
here the program that would be at the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page or you can
go to the amazing facts
Facebook page I am Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross good evening friends
and pastor Decker's boys do let's start
the program with prayer dear father we
thank you that we're able to take a few
moments to open up your word and study
together and we ask your blessing upon
the program if you were those who are
listening wherever they might be across
the country and in some cases around the
world Lord that your spirit would speak
to our hearts give us a clear
understanding of your will and word in
Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor day I open the program by
talking about some very big doors it's
almost hard teammate in something that
big of course we've seen pictures of the
the rockets and space shuttle that been
assembled in this big building and then
of course they opened the doors and they
roll these things out on massive tracts
but you made sure takes about 45 minutes
to open up close the doors yeah
absolutely and they are you know when
they assembled the space
run under rocket Saturn 5 and others
were put together in this building for
the moon launch and they had
to have a protected environment there's
also security issues and and so they had
to find a building but what do you do
once you built this big rocket in the
building you got to get it out so they
had to say we're gonna have to build the
biggest doors in the world I remember as
a kid watching King Kong and the
explorers come up to this massive wall
they're going what in the world would
you need a wall that big for and then
they see the doors and they go what in
the world would you ever need doors that
big for him and I'll tell you these
doors at the Space Center there at
Kennedy there they're like 10 times King
Kong size and they are big doors but I
was teasing at the beginning the Bible
talks about a door that is even bigger
you know they say what's the biggest
room in the world it's a room for
improvement I used to get a Cracker
Jacks joke and said what's the smallest
room it's a mushroom
but the biggest door is the door of
salvation and Jesus said in John chapter
10 I am the door if anyone enters by me
he will be saved
of course he says another place if
anyone tries to go over the wall or
around the door there a thief and a
robber they're not going to make it the
only way one door is through Christ and
many of us know this story in the Bible
of Noah's Ark and Bible tells us that
all of life was saved on that vehicle
but there was only one door and God
opened that door and God shut the door
and and Jesus says that he stands at the
door of our hearts and he knocks and if
we open the door of our hearts he comes
in and that's one way we go through that
door of salvation is by inviting him
into our hearts and do we have a special
offer that talks about how they can take
advantage of that door they don't have
to wait 45 minutes you can get her outta
way we have a book it's cold three steps
to heaven it's talking about what we
need to do in order to come into a
saving relationship with God it's really
good news and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks this
is our free offer today so if you'd like
to receive it just call the number 800
eight three five six seven four seven
that is
resource phone line and as for the book
called three steps to heaven we'll get
it right out to you again it's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and if you have a Bible question
then I'm gonna call here to the studio
is eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven again it's eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven we
do have phone lines that are open so
this is a good time at the beginning of
the program to get your Bible question
to us and we'll do our best to study it
out together first call this evening is
Richard listening in Montana Richard
welcome to the program okay
read the King James okay okay okay
so that's part of applicator 27 and 28
know Paul's a prison and so on so forth
I think it's put on that I'm called
Malita Quinn house yeah the island a
Malta I've actually been there but yes
go ahead
okay so anyway yeah I gotta do a little
bit of traveling eventually and I get
the one place the 15 way come across
some believers and the question is it
says when Paul saw three taverns ah he's
saying thought like I'm going to last
two waters of Versailles know what type
of taverns were they talking about and
already be thinking down to those three
taverns yeah somebody might be wondering
here does it some you say a tavern you
know an old England have been a saloon
you know then and so was Paul stayin at
the three saloons for but the word
tavern there in the original I think it
was tab aroun and it it means an inn
that's what Ross was looking that up cuz
we saw a Richards question it means an
inn or could be a marketplace it's both
in just a place for actually a place to
stay like an end but there were also
shops and it appears that it could very
well be the name of a town they called
it the three ends and just as a
gathering not a big
but a place where people could spend the
night and buy their their needs so
that's probably why he thanks God and
took courage they were traveling and
they came to a place where they could
stay and there were Christians or they
were able to share with them so I took
courage there yep actually also says
there as far as the a bi forum and
that's the the same word that's used to
talk about that famous Roman Road the
Appian Way there you know the roads of
Rome some of them are still in existence
today that we're late in the time of
Christ they used stone and granite miles
and miles of it was slave labor and real
famous one it's actually got the chariot
wheels ruts worn right into the stone is
called the Appian Way and so this was a
part of that network of roads thank you
for your question Richard we appreciate
it
we've got Becky listening in Michigan
Becky welcome to the program hello how
are you happy new year thank you you too
um I have a question on Revelation 12:17
see um I meant to ask what the spirit of
prophecy is that may get me worrying
this but what is the testimony of Jesus
Christ
alright yeah if you look in Revelation
12 and I'll just read this for people
who are listening talks about Revelation
12 is dealing with this woman who brings
forth a man child and there's a dragon
that wants to devour the man child but
he's caught up to God's throne this is
of course Christ and the woman
represents the church through the ages
that was looking for the Messiah that
was to announce her bring forth the
Messiah to the world and when the dragon
could no longer reach the Messiah he
goes to make war with the woman and her
descendants that have two outstanding
characteristics they keep the
commandments of God and they have the
testimony of Jesus now those two phrases
are found through the Bible and it
really means the law and the prophets
the testimony of Jesus if you look in
Revelation 19 verse 10 it says an angel
speaking to the Apostle John it says
worship God from of your
fellow surfers the profits for that
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy and as adye's a ax8 where it
says I think it's verse 16 bind up the
law seal bind up the testimony seal the
law among my disciples and it's in verse
20 of Isaiah ethier it says according to
the law in the testimony last phrases in
the Old Testament behold I send you
Elijah he was the greatest of the
prophets and remember the law of Moses
you got Moses and Elijah the law and the
prophets
these two individuals appear to Jesus on
the Mount of Transfiguration and Mark
chapter 9 the law and the prophets it's
all talking about the word of God and
the last day church is going to have the
Word of God they're gonna have the
spirit of prophecy and they're gonna
believe the law in the prophets and so
these are two characteristics of the
church in the last days you know Becky
we do have a book that we'll be happy to
send you a copy of it's called the
glorious mount talks about the two
witnesses and it talks about the law and
the prophets the number the cold for
that is just simply our resource phone
line that's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and you can
answer the book called the glorious
mountain and we'll be able to send that
out to anyone who calls and asks thank
you for your call Becky next caller that
we have these misty listening from looks
like Arizona misty welcome to the
program hi hi misty thanks for calling
and your question oh sorry okay okay did
you want me to read it did you want to
read it all right it says here in
Deuteronomy 14 21 you shall not eat
anything that dies of itself you might
give it to the alien who is within your
gates that he may eat it or you may sell
it to a foreigner for your holy people
to the Lord your God and then it says
you shall not boil a young goat in its
mother's milk was there were you
wondering about don't anything die of
itself or the goat in the mother's milk
know that you don't eat anything that
died but you can give it to somebody
else I was so that was enough because we
practice the Golden Rule don't do to
others what they wanted to do to you so
I was wondering why should we do that to
our neighbor yeah that's a good question
the if first of all when it says
something that dies of itself God's
people were supposed to be holy and
there were certain laws that actually
applied to them that didn't apply
necessarily to the Gentiles or the
stranger among them it wasn't talking
about eating an unclean food it meant
you know if you got a goat and it got
old and died you don't eat it you can
give it to hungry people that maybe
aliens that don't have the same scruples
and so you know the Lord was saying
you've got a higher standard because you
are my people so but at the same time
there might be hungry people and they
didn't want it to go to waste I don't
think they're saying that if any you
know if a plague goes through and all
your animals get sick and die and
they're your you think of someone's
gonna get sick if they eat it that you
give it to them I don't think the Lord
is suggesting you give something sick to
anybody alrighty thank you appreciate
your call misty next full of the babies
Rebecca listening from Washington
Rebecca welcome to the program hi hey
thanks for calling yeah so my question
um I was reading my Bible lesson the
other day about Saul visiting the Witch
of Endor and for Samuel 29 yeah and it
was just kind of confusing to me the way
it's worded because it said like you
know what do you see and she said I see
a God coming up out of the earth wrapped
in a robe and and it said Saul realized
it was Samuel and and and and it said
and Samuel said blah blah blah you know
you're gonna because you haven't obeyed
God then the Philistines are gonna you
know you're gonna die tomorrow and
battled and I guess it just
the wording is confusing to me because
sounds like it my own Sam you yeah but I
don't you know believe that it really
was but I thought maybe they didn't
understand about Satan's angels at that
point in history or something I just
wasn't quite sure what to think since
well I think I don't think it was Samuel
no well and there's another passage I'm
guessing pastor also looking that up
right now
but you got to keep in mind this is
being written from the perspective of
why Saul did what he did he believed it
was Samuel and so the very fact they had
to say what do you see
and the witch is telling them what she's
seen tells you that something's
suspicious going on here and this is why
God said do not go to witches they can
create illusions that are very
convincing but there's another passage
on this story that's in chronicles I
believe yea first chronicles chapter 10
verse 13 which makes it clear that Paul
a rather soul soul died because he let
me read the verse so Saul died for his
transgression we should committed
against the Lord even against the word
of the Lord which he did not keep and
also for asking counsel of one who had a
familiar spirit to inquire of it so
there's quite clear that this is not say
a meal the Prophet but it was a madea
spirit yeah and when where's the verse
where it talks about Armageddon
I'm having a brain cramp II and the
three unclean spirits like frogs come
out of the meat mouth of the Beast out
of the mouth of the false prophet the
dragon revelation 16:13 Aaron alright I
was almost there let me see here let me
read this to you here it says for they
are the spirits of demon performing
signs that go out to the kings of the
earth to gather them to the Battle this
is exactly what happened to Saul an evil
spirit deceived him before he went into
battle and that battle was his undoing
and the last day is what's what the
devil is going to do again and it's
called the Battle of Armageddon and and
you know the wicked and the the devil
and those that follow him lose in that
battle so it's
harkening back revelation is kind of
talking about these evil spirits
they're called lying spirits spirits
that work miracles and so that's why
Jesus said there's gonna be a lot of
false prophets and there'll be signs and
wonders don't believe the false prophets
because they can do convincing things I
think it's 2nd Corinthians 11 it's the
Satan himself is transformed into an
angel of light and I understand that
theology it was just confusing to me the
way it worded well you're right it was
just so strange it's because I mean I I
honored I was like wait a second it's an
evil spirit
but the way that it's worded is like
sounds like it's the same he realized it
Samuel and I thought well why doesn't
the Bible make it more clear there so
that it was an evil spirit that which
venner was talking to instead of making
it sound like almost like it was Samuel
yeah I think what it's doing there is
it's trying to let us know that we're
looking at it through the perspective of
saul and in the very fact they weren't
supposed to see a witch the other thing
is does the devil have power to
resurrect of course not and the witches
and mediums cannot bring back the dead
the only one who can give life the only
one who has the keys of the grave it
says in Revelation is Jesus and so but
they are seducing spirits the Bible
tells us so you're right first glance
might confuse a person so you got to do
some background study to see that this
was just an apparition you know we do
have a study guide that deals with the
subject of what happens when a person
dies and it's called all the dead really
dead can they communicate for the living
we'll be happy to send the study out to
anyone who calls and asks the number
that you want to call he's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and again just after that study guide
called other dead really dead now he
also have a website that folks might
want to take a look at it's called death
truth comm and you'll be able to read a
number of Bible verses on that subject
we even have a study called The Witch of
Endor yeah talks about this subject to
so you even just type in The Witch of
Endor amazing facts you'll it'll
probably pop up the study and you could
read that for free online
well that frees up another line pastor
oz who
next we got Joseph listening in
Pennsylvania Joseph welcome to the
program thank you very much thank you
for taking my call thank you and your
record I had a question yes I had a
question about the Lord's Prayer since
the two different versions in Matthew 6
and Luke 11 seems to end the prayer
differently I just wanted to mention
that I noticed something in Luke 1 it
seems to close with deliver us from the
evil one that some verses later it
actually continues and does say if
you're not little flock for it is your
father's good pleasure to give you the
kingdom Jesus addressing his disciples
when that indicate that Matthews version
agrees with that with when when Jesus
says for thine is the kingdom he's
actually addressing the disciples rather
than his father
well the question they're asking in
Matthew is they start out and say teach
us to pray and actually in Luke I'm
sorry it says you know Lord teaches the
Grays John taught his disciples and he
says pray in this manner so what the
Lord is giving them is it's an outline
for prayer it's a model for prayer
you know nowhere in the Bible doesn't
say repeat this prayer and it's really
he's giving and there's seven petitions
there if you look in Matthew and he's
talking three pretty matter-of-fact it's
divided like the Ten Commandments the
first four Commandments or 40 percent
deal with our relationship with God and
the last 60 percent deal with our
relationship with our fellow man the
Lord's Prayer is the divide it up the
same way it's hallowed be your name your
kingdom your will and then the last part
is give us our bread forgive us our
debts lead us and deliver us and so it's
talking about the horizontal
relationship it's beautifully laid out
you're finding the same principle in
Luke so either version if a person
there's nothing wrong with repeating the
Lord's Prayer but jesus said don't pray
in vain repetition so nowhere are we
told to say the prayer over and over
again matter of fact he says don't pray
in vain repetition
and thinking you get you know extra
credit like the pagan for their much
speaking so um but it is the perfect
model for prayer now I'm gonna put you
back on Joe so if you had a little
background noise does that answer your
question yes very much thank you very
much
all right thanks I appreciate your call
and we do have a book that will send you
that's about the Lord's Prayer and it's
called teach us to pray we'll be happy
to send that out to anyone who calls and
asks our resource phone line as we
mentioned before he's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can answer the book called teach
us to pray we'll send that out to anyone
who calls and asks you can also go to
the amazing facts website just amazing
facts about our ji and you'll be able to
read that book there as well next hole
of the behalf is Lucas listening in
Alaska Lucas walking with the program hi
can you hear me we hear ya hi Lucas
thanks for calling hi I just wanted to
know how I could get started in this
whole road to a Christian life well I
love that question do you mind my asking
what is making you decide to be a
Christian it just seems like the right
thing to do I like the whole lifestyle
I like the idea I want to get better at
it well the first and most important
thing the word Christian means a
follower of Christ so it starts and ends
with Jesus which is it's God God's Son
God became a man to show us what the
father is like he came to be our example
and ultimately he came to die in our
place as our sacrifice for our sins
knowing how much he loves us that he was
willing to die and suffer for our sins
rather than lose us usually touches our
hearts and what he wants is he says I
want you to love me with your hearts he
can't force love we must choose and if
we say Lord I believe that you do love
me and I love you and I want to love you
more you come to him in prayer you
invite him into your heart you see I'm
gonna give you my my life and even
though you may feel struggles
the future and second-guess your
decision say Lord I'm yours and as you
surrender yourself to him you then give
him power you give him permission to
activate God the spirit in your life and
you'll hear God speaking to you guiding
you you'll bring peace into your life
you'll feel conviction when temptation
comes and it's the power of God just
moves into your heart so it through
prayer and faith you come to him just
like you are you know go ahead I'm sorry
my question is important to be going to
church every Sunday or every Sunday and
Wednesday or can I do this out of my own
bedroom well you should start on your
knees with the Lord in a relationship
and then a couple of keys to growing
it's just like a baby you need to feed
your soul and you need the fellowship of
other people you know one of the most
important things pastor when you're
talking about growing as a Christian is
to take some time to study to read the
word and you know Lucas we do have a set
of Bible study guides that is free that
amazing facts provides kind of helps
people in their Bible study especially
somebody that is new to the Christian
life and we'd be happy to send that to
you all you're left to do is just call
and simply ask say I'd like to enroll in
the amazing facts Bible study course and
we'll send that out to you or anyone
that would like to learn more the number
is just 883 five six seven four seven
and again just ask to enroll in the
Bible study cause of the amazing facts
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven lucas you still there yes I
am could I have a prayer week yeah let
me just pray with you real quick father
in heaven I'm just so thankful for the
way your spirit is working in Lucas
heart he is reaching out to you right
now lord I pray that he can know that
you're drawing him and that you'll give
him the peace that comes from
surrendering his life to you I pray that
you just strengthen his faith in the
love of your son and his sacrifice for
you and let this be a newbie
inning for him we pray in Jesus name
Amen amen
oh alright look it's sin for those
studies and you'll be very thankful you
did all right next call that's why we do
this program that's right that's
exciting
no do we have time past we got about a
minute you know maybe we should hold off
taking another caller we're not done
with the program we're just gonna take a
break here in a little bit but before we
do that we did mention the website
pastor that amazing facts Dorji for
anyone who has never visited the website
before you want to take a look at that
absolutely and you know our website is
like layers and layers of wonderful
information three things you can read
videos you can watch studies you can do
online there's a devotional you can sign
up for and just there's a reason it's
one of the top Christian websites
amazing facts com that's amazing
well amazing facts not o RG or amazing
facts com we also have a TV station
called AF TV 24 hours a day you can
watch streaming Christian programs at
a-f-t-v dot o-r-g we're gonna just take
a brief break get a drink of water let's
our stations ID themselves and we're
coming back with more questions give us
a call with your Bible questions we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and include the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dhic index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers seek his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com every bible
question you have answered moves you one
step closer to the fullness of God's
will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at 1-800-805-3030
and Jean Ross for more Bible answers
live are back we're back friends welcome
to Bible answers live if you're joining
along the way it's just what it says we
are answering Bible questions live we
invite you to call in with our questions
we have a couple lines open 804 six
three seven two 97 I am Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross and I mexico look
at me heavies oh but i listening in
canada oh but i welcome to the program
pastors mean taking my call
so my question is about prayer and how
prayers are answered I mean you've been
talking to some of my friends and you
know these things that you know it costs
that you can pray can be on your knees
you pray for a wife you pray for your
car pray for your house or anything and
your prayer is answered by the devil
instead I know that the Bible says I you
know it pray and you shall receive but
is that possible really that you end up
with you know a very stressful situation
because your prayer wasn't answered by
God well let me give you an example now
there is a verse master Ross might look
it up for me where it talks about your
prayers be not hindered
I think that's talking about husbands
treating your wife wives well that your
prayers be not hindered but God told
Abraham I'm going to give you a promise
child and Abraham was praying for a
child with Sarah but he became impatient
along the way and when Sarah showed up
with her maidservant and said well look
you know it doesn't look like God's
gonna answer your prayer
why don't you use a Hagar as a surrogate
Abraham thought well I guess that's
God's answer well that was the devil's
answer to his prayer because he lost
patience so you know there are a few
cases in the Bible where you could say
God will test to see do we believe that
he's going to answer our prayer if we
wait upon him sometimes we become
impatient Saul lost patience waiting for
Samuel to come during a battle and he
offered sacrifice he was being tested if
he had waited he would have had a
marvelous victory and so sometimes I
think the devil will try to intercept
what God wants to do for us because we
become impatient or we lose faith well
make sure that you're if God makes a
promise that you wait for the promise
according to his word in the two cases I
just mentioned they both had specific
Commandments from the God
God said I'm going to give you a child
through Sarah and God told Saul wait for
Samuel wait seven days and he stopped
waiting so God if we just wait on the
Lord according to his word sometimes the
devil will try and intercept God's
prayers and say I've got a better way
but it means compromise so don't
compromise you won't have to worry about
the devil intercepting your prayers
well thanks a lot appreciate that and
you'll enjoy the book that we mentioned
earlier on teach us to pray it's got
some of the principles of prayer and
answered prayer but a good question over
diet we appreciate that then I'm gonna
call if you'd like to receive the book
he's eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven and again after the
book called teach us to pray we'll send
it to anyone who calls and asks we've
got Patrick listening also in Canada in
Toronto Patrick welcome to the program
hello Doctor sorry pastor price and doug
batchelor thank you for calling and your
question my question I was my very first
time calling it and I very much support
and love this program by the way well
wait thank you my question is there's a
teaching going on in the church in some
churches today I'm not sure how huge it
is but it's a book of Godhead also known
as a variant teaching I believe I just
want to find out is the Holy Spirit from
God is he from risking God the Son or is
the Holy Spirit and individual you know
this is a subject that has been deeply
studied and debated for 2,000 years
maybe longer the Hebrews probably
debated it too but the most of the
Christian world has agreed that the
Scriptures teach that the Holy Spirit is
a distinct and separate person but is
equal with the Godhead of the father and
the son
the fact that Jesus would say baptized
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit and if you look in
Genesis you've got God saying let us
make man in our image and the spirit
moved on the face of the waters and then
you get to Revelation and it says even
the spirit and the bride say come it
doesn't just say Jesus come or the
father come the Spirit says come so
going from cover to cover I just wrote a
book on this because a lot of people
were asking questions and I was
encouraged by this study that I think
there's a good biblical foundation
that the Holy Spirit is a unique
distinct person of God of the Godhead
and that's why you know the word Trinity
is not in the Bible but it's it's just a
teaching it's a label for a teaching of
the three entities of God and God the
Father the Son and the Spirit but when
God said you know let us make man in our
image it's plural and he Moses says hear
o Israel the Lord our God is one but one
for the Hebrew meant unity you know
Jesus said to the Apostles you are one
but there were twelve of them yes
because in this in the same teaching
they teach that I'm in heaven before the
fall that it was God the Father God the
Son and Lucifer and I find that to be a
very dangerous teaching because they're
trying to say that Lucifer in turn is
part of the Godhead which he did she
wasn't no Lucifer yeah one thing that
separates God from all of the other
beings in the universe is that God is
self-existent
he has not been created he's from
everlasting to everlasting of the devil
and pastor ross is this an ezekiel it
says from the day you were perfect from
the day you were created I sometimes get
Ezekiel 20 and Isaiah 14 mixed up but I
think it says you are perfect from the
day you are created Lucifer was created
he's not a create he's a creation
yep Ezekiel chapter 28 verse 15 now we
do have a book on that subject that
pastor Doug has written and I'm trying
to think pastor day we might have
updated the the title is it called the
Trinity or is it well if they if they
call and ask for the book on the Trinity
I think they'll get the new book call
called 1 or 3 and it's about the Trinity
subject one God or three so the number
to call is 808 three five six seven four
seven and again just asked for the book
on the Trinity called one God or three
and we'll be happy to send the trainee
when it calls and asks we've got Donna
listening in North Carolina
Donna welcome to the program well hi guy
hey thank you for calling
oh thanks for taking my call and what's
on your heart tonight just a little
confusion and I'm sure you guys can
clarify in Matthew chapter 13 it talks
of a man that serves good seed in his
field and while they slept
enemy came and sowed tares among them
yes so whenever they went to harvest the
servants asked what they should do and
he said we'll gather up the tares first
and bind them to burn and then gather
the wheat into my barn well later on in
Matthew chapter 24 around verse 40 it
says there shall be two in the field the
one shall be taken and the other left
two women shall be grinding at the mill
the one shall be taken in the other left
now those bursts is related as far as
the one taken is the tares and the ones
left are the weak and if so the I heard
a preacher one time say I want to be the
one taken so is he an error
yeah well that that passage there that
you find both in Matthew and in Luke
about two women in the field Luke adds a
third one I think Luke says there's also
two men sleeping in a bed Matthew says
two women in the field two men two women
grinding bread two men in the field and
the ones taken away folks are shocked
because the whole Left Behind scenario
in people's minds misunderstand that
passage it says that the flood came and
took away the unbelievers as in the days
of Noah so will the coming of the Son of
man be where they were eating and
drinking I think that is that Luke 17
pastor Russ and marrying and building
and they knew not until the flood came
and took them away well you think the
ones taken away or saved but know that
taken away in judgment and the reason we
know is the disciples say Jesus where it
says wherever the body is that's where
the vultures the eagles are gathered and
so the just to understand the mindset of
the
when the Hebrews were well behaved the
Jews they got to stay in the promised
land when they misbehaved the Assyrians
came and took them away the Babylonians
came and took them away and so the worst
judgment would be to be taken away from
the promised land
and the blessing would be to be able to
stay so it's talking about judgment
taking him away and just like the wheat
and the tares it says the other the the
wicked are taken away in judgment while
the meek will inherit the earth they get
to survive all right that actually
clarified that so yeah that's a good
question a lot of people are surprised
when they hear that they think that the
two women in the field and the tomb are
the two women grinding two men in the
field him in the bed is talking about
the secret rapture taking place
poof one is taken away and and it's
really Jesus didn't mean anything like
that to women represent the two kinds of
churches when the Lord comes grinding
the bread sharing the word two men
working in the field Christ says the
field is the world
two men sleeping in a bed there's two
kinds of dead people is the righteous
and the Lost and now we've got a booklet
we can send you Don and it's called
anything but secret talks about that I
think these verses are included in that
the number to call if you'd like to
receive that is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
again you can ask for the book on the
second coming it's called anything but
secret and we'll get it right out to you
thanks for your cold on we've got mark
listening in Canada mark welcome to the
program hi yeah it's my turn okay so I
have a quick question but there's a
little backstory about it okay I grew up
in abusive homes group homes and things
like that and was that on my own at a
very young age I have all abd and Irlen
syndrome so because of my past as an
adult I find it really hard to trust
people to get close to people and
communicate with people but Jesus said
that not all of us should become
teachers in 3-1 or sorry James 3:1 and I
want to save our faith with people but I
have really bad communication
problems so I don't want things to come
out of my mouth in a corrupt fashion
like it says in Ephesians 4:29 so I was
just wondering how does someone like me
share their faith well start small you
don't have to go from believer to teach
her over night share what the Lord is
given on your heart and you can do it in
bite-sized pieces and you just described
me I bounced around between 14 different
schools you can ask Pastor Ross I've got
an attention deficit I'm chasing
squirrels all the time I'm so easily
distracted
I see everything it comes to my mind and
it's taken me years to learn how to kind
of measure and throttle my mouth and I
still I'm not sure I've learned it so I
know exactly how you feel and but over
the years God has has given me wisdom
that comes with time if the Lord is
calling me to share your faith doesn't
mean you need to be a full time Bible
teacher but just you know ask the Lord
to give you wisdom to recognize the
opportunities ask him to give you tact
diplomacy so that you can do it in a
gentle way and do it in small bites and
you know anything you do you get better
at okay great I was also wanting to say
thank you very much because it's because
of discovering your videos on YouTube
that I actually came to accept Jesus and
to you know to start reading the Bible
and all that and I really actually like
how you talk because you're the only
pastor that I've ever been able to
understand so oh well thank you very
much
well that's because you and I both have
ATD that's why you understand yeah well
thank you so much mark we sure
appreciate your kind words and bless
your heart if you've not done the
amazing fact study guides and if you
sign up we'll send that to you free and
it'll change your life
if you'd like to get it mailed to you
which we encourage is just simply call
the number eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and ask that
you be enrolled in the free amazing fact
study guide course and you'll learn so
much through the various lessons that we
have we've got Jessica listening from
Florida Jessica welcome to the program
I could do evening postures good evening
Jessica thank you for calling and your
question yes question but can I have two
quick questions well let's see how long
the first one is okay the Joel chapter 2
verse 28 and it says that I shall come
to pass afterward that I will pour out
my spirit on all flesh what does he mean
by all flesh
everybody not even those so doesn't
really believe in God no I think when
he's saying I'll pour out my spirit on
all flesh in the next verses he
describes what he means he's not just
going to do it on professional priests
and prophets he said I'll do it on your
children I'll do it on the boys I'll do
it on the girls I'll do it on the old
I'll do it on the young I'll do it on
your servants I'll do it on your men's
servants and your maid servants so all
flesh he describes in the next verses he
said believers from every part of the
culture the young the old the men the
women the servants the the the rich the
poor but I don't think he's saying he's
gonna give his spirit to wicked people
and they're gonna prophesy he's talking
about God every time we read the Bible
when it say all not some something like
that right like yeah I think he started
what would help in in Hebrew I think
he's really saying I will pour out my
spirit on all kinds of people
flesh means you know a technical you
could say all flesh and that could say
goats and sheep and camels he's gonna
pour out his spirit so he he describes
in the next few verses that he's going
to give a spirit to everybody not just
the priests and the prophets and Kings
like David but what was your other
question you said you had a quick one
yeah the one that unpardonable sin
aníbal seem that they have no hope
anymore well I'm sure there are some you
know we've seen in the Bible there are
people in the Old Testament really I'm
ok yeah I don't think that a Christian
commits the unpardonable sin because if
you're Christian then you know God's
working in your life and and hopefully
you're still growing in grace there are
people who can be Christians and grieve
away the Holy Spirit at one point King
Saul had the Holy Spirit and God even
called him but he became proud and over
a process of years it doesn't happen
quickly he grieved away the Spirit so he
was finally killing the priests he
became very evil and he grieved away the
spirit when actually went to Witch of
Endor I think his probation closed at
that point and you've got Balaam the
Prophet who grieved away the spirit he
finally counseled Balak how to bring
down God's people and he died in battle
I think he grieved away the spirit of
course Judas he betrayed Christ and even
when Jesus was washing his feet
Judas probably could have been forgiven
if he had repented and confessed but he
hardened his heart he went out the Bible
says he went out it was night and Satan
and Satan entered him I think at that
point Judas had committed the
unpardonable sin so but people out there
thinking oh I think I've gone too far
you know 99.9 percent of the time when
people think I've committed the
unpardonable sin the devil wants them to
think that so they lose hope when in
reality if they'd repent God would
forgive them so you don't want anyone to
get discouraged and lose hope all right
Thank You Jessica oh Jessica by the way
we do have a book on the unpardonable
sin you can ask for it it's simply
called what is the unpardonable sin the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and again just ask - the book called
what is the unpardonable sin we'll be
happy to send that to anyone who calls
we've got sherry listening in Montana
sherry welcome to the program hello hi
my hi how are you good and your question
my question is is Michael the Archangel
a
good angel or a bad angel I get kind of
confused I've heard things where people
try to make it a good angel but yet I've
wondered if it's actually a bad angel no
I think Michael is a good angel and the
reason we believe this sherry is if well
let me give you a few different verses
and then we even have a book we'll offer
you
Michael is the one fighting the devil in
Revelation 12 says the dragon the devil
and his angels fights with Michael in
his angels Michael is leading the good
angels in that battle Michael is the one
who descends from heaven with the voice
of the Lord it says the Lord will
descend with the voice of the Archangel
and called the dead to life Michael is
the one who comes and argues with the
devil to rescue Moses from the grave
when Moses is resurrect and that's Jude
verse 9 only one chapter in Jude Jude
verse 9 and Michael is a great Prince
that stands for the children of thy
people you find in Daniel chapter 12 so
Michaels he's on the good side and we
have a book sherry it's called who is
Michael the Archangel I think you'll
love the study it's really encouraging
we'll send you a free copy yes the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the book called who
he's Michael the Archangel you can also
read that if you just go to the amazing
facts website you can read it right now
or call and we'll be happy to send that
to you we've got Trudy listening from
New York
Trudy welcome to the program hi my
question is that my dad asked me this
and I didn't really know how to answer
him he wanted to know if it how do we
know that was the Apostle John who wrote
revelation and not some other follower
of Jesus named John well John was a
common name it does say John in verse
four it says John to the seven churches
there's several ways we know and almost
no Bible scholar contests this first of
all you know the early church fathers
all attributed the book of Revelation of
John he says that he was on the
Isle of Patmos when he wrote this we
know that John the Apostle was
imprisoned on the Isle of Patmos history
bears witness to that the style of
writing is very much like John that you
find in the Gospel of John in the three
letters of John maybe pastor Ross is
more to add to that he likes revelation
yes I think just in Chapter one when you
read the introductory comments that's
made and of course he identifies himself
as having the spirit of prophecy in
verse one we know that John was a
prophet and this is a special revelation
given by God we believe that the timing
for the book of Revelation somewhere
around 90 AD John being the youngest of
the twelve at this time he's an old man
the other apostles had already given
their life for their faith but John the
last survivor of the Apostles quite
possibly the past of the Church of
Ephesus prior to this he was taken from
there to Patmos yeah and so you've got
verse 4 where it says John to the seven
churches in verse 9 he says I John both
your brother and companion in the
tribulation and the kingdom and patience
of Jesus and he's also writing from a
position of leadership in the church
with authority of an apostle only
certain people who knew Jesus personally
and had that relationship so all the
early church fathers that knew John
attributed revelation to him I've not
read too many that that argue that it
was somebody else does that help Trudy
yes thank you very much all right hey
thanks so much and you'd enjoy the if
you haven't read at the advanced amazing
fact study guide where it goes into some
of the prophecies of Revelation and you
can find those online it's simply
amazing facts dot o-r-g we have time for
one more call pastor we've got let's see
Brent is listening from south-korea
brain welcome to the program hello can
you hear me okay
loud and clear yes good to be on the air
that's the first time I've ever done it
well thanks for calling we got about two
minutes so we'll do our best with what
we have okay
my question is about
doesn't contradict itself I I wondered
if you could help me with the parable of
the rich man and Lazarus which of course
is just a parable and you know
Ecclesiastes 9:5 believe says I believe
that the dead know not anything so of
course on the one hand we know from
Ecclesiastes 9:5 and a bunch of other
verses that you know that is true and
how do we know that they're parable the
rich man and Lazarus is not endorsing
the idea that man has an immortal oh all
right very good appreciate that and and
I'll tell you in just a moment
Brent we do also have a free book for
anyone that wants it just came out and
it's on the rich man and Lazarus if you
ask for Doug bachelors book on the rich
man and Lazarus we'll send it to you
free it's a sermon book I did but it's a
I think a pretty complete study the
couple of ways we know that it's a
parable for one thing it would be absurd
to think the people in heaven and hell
are going to be able to talk to each
other
furthermore the rich man says if you
could send Lazarus with a drop of water
by the way this is in Luke chapter 16
that's where you find the parable he
says if you could send wait as though
Luke 18 Luke 18 no no beginning in verse
16 thanking that's not Luke 18 I just
had to care and I lost it
oh we're getting old here I just wanted
to give the verse out and I got all
distracted with it but um or you keep
talking I'll find it yeah it's only
found in one place in the Gospel of Luke
but in this passage it's telling us that
a drop of water is not going to cool a
person's tongue if they're burning in in
Hellfire some people think well it must
be a true story because Jesus uses the
named Lazarus well the reason Jesus uses
the named Lazarus is the end of the
parable he says oh but if someone went
from my father's house resurrected then
they believed and he said look if
Lazarus even went back to your father's
house if they don't believe Moses in the
prophets they won't believe Lazarus
either
and so Jesus raised someone from the
dead by the name of Lazarus Luke 16:19
that's so it I think is most certainly
parable please do send for our book a
new book on the rich man and Lazarus and
Brent eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven to order that and you
can also probably get to it amazing
facts dot o-r-g and listening friends
that want to be fair to someone if we
took another call if we did not get your
call tonight we hope you'll give us
another chance next week and we want to
remind you that so much of what we share
and even archives of these programs you
can find out amazing facts dot o-r-g
click there and pray that you'll pass
the link on to your friends god bless
we'll study together again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
journey back through time to the center
of the universe discover how a perfect
angel transformed into Satan the arch
villain the birth of evil a rebellion in
heaven immediately that moved to earth
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
written by the hand of God and spoken
with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore com for over fifty
years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world we build churches in India
proclaim God's Word in China and have
sent free Bible studies around the globe
today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners
caring individuals like you if you've
been blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website
[Music]
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at $887
may sing fax 0 RG
[Music]